I'm Alec Baldwin and you are seconds
away from seeing a sneak peak of
DreamWorks new animated film the boss
baby I'm so excited for you really I've
got that whole butterfly in the tummy
thing going on the temple teams were
making plans for their newest addition
[Music]
this baby has other plans
we babies are having a crisis babies
aren't getting as much love as we used
to behold our mortal enemy
Oh No that's exactly the problem
have you learned anything hey Vee no
what have you learned about puppies hey
puppy no Jimbo puppies are evil Stacey
be back the notes I can't read what's it
say boss period oh it's like they're
having their own little meeting watch
dessert this is so humiliating you've
got the right baby than this job I know
how important this mission is to the
company mission
poop duty I got a deal with the K ID who
are you I'm on a mission there's not
enough love to go around my job is to
find out why they'll give me a double
espresso and see if there's someplace
around here with decent sushi I kill for
a spicy tuna roll right about now this
is war
oh look the kids are finally getting
along that's nice if I don't succeed
with this mission I will live here
forever with you okay I will help you
but just to get rid of you deal here
comes a joke agree no no you're watching
cute okay
choo-choo on that how do we get past the
guard I've never been so humiliated in
my life
[Music]
from this way
better bring me Oh I don't we're not
gonna sniff it done to me what's all the
racket isn't he adorable oh I've got one
for you too what bummer
Green Works the bus baby put that cookie
down cookies are for closers
look at him he wears a suit he's like a
little man
he carries a briefcase there's no one
else things that's oh I don't know a
little freaky
will you carry lamb-lamb around until
you like this is not about lamb lamb
you